good morning John it's Friday and I have
a gigantic journal of all of the things
that I thought about in high school and
boy where there are a lot of things
there's also like things like this fancy
illustrations of organic compounds I'm
not getting more dorky but that's for
sure I don't think that you could get
much more dorky than this which appears
to be but I think it may be the first
step in the krebs cycle a lot of power
off nothing has changed
not getting any better flogging it's
actually not true I've been going back
and watching a lot of old Brotherhood
2.0 videos and I'm very very certain
that I'm getting better at vlogging
there a plug and now you won't do that
anymore thank you I approached this task
attempting to find funny things I found
plenty of funny things but I was
surprised by the number from not at all
funny things that I found there also
just some things that I'm really sort of
shocked about like I was really obsessed
with this box diagram thing which I was
using to try and simplify personal
interactions as well as people's like
ideas of what they wanted to do with
their lives and what they would and
would not do if I don't really get it
can't remember and I can't understand
what the frick I'm trying to do here and
it's really is sort of laid out in a lot
of detail but I still don't understand
what I'm talking about for the most part
and then throughout the journal I'm
always talking about people's red boxes
and their green boxes and I don't
understand what I'm talking about also
um the songwriting thing is not new I
thought that the songwriting thing was
newer than it was I remember that I
wrote some songs in high school but I
did not realize how many songs I wrote
in high school I also now realize why I
write funny songs because when I write
songs that are serious they are
invariably very very bad we've got
everything from like rants against
capitalism too raunchy er than mm kind
of things I am afraid that I can't
really share any of that with you for
fear of embarrassment slash fear getting
flagged is inappropriate on YouTube
let's see if I can at least find some
song lyrics to share with you because
that would quell some of your suspicions
okay this is embarrassing
well I'm sitting at my Pentium CPU
working on some very which is the plural
of virus thinking about how much times
have changed since I got my Apple 2e
my life kicks ass I love technology I'm
in class tripping down with zero-g I
don't know who or what zero-g is was and
I don't know what tripping down is but
apparently I'd like to rap about hacking
earlier in this journal I was saying how
much my life kick ass and now I'm saying
how much my life sucks contradiction has
been a pretty big theme I've noticed in
this journal but in short it's pretty
obvious that I was trying to figure a
lot of things out from God to girls to
computers to biochemistry all of it sort
of like jumbled together into me being
really angst like if I was a parent and
I found this journal and I read some of
it I would be legitimately concerned for
the safety and well-being of my child I
would also be concerned for the safety
and well-being of children near him like
oh this stuff's pretty screwed up I will
say however that John you managed to be
in this journal several times I was
never in your journal but you are in my
journal at least twice I wrote a little
bit about you and Marie that's right
Marie and apparently we were talking
about phenomenology or something I don't
know I don't trust anything I write
because I don't think that I knew what
phenomenology was then because I've kind
of forgotten what it is now what I'm
taking away from this is that I'm really
glad that I wrote down all this stuff
not because I want to read it now have a
really hard time like a lot of the pages
look like this and like there literally
is no punctuation I guess what I'm
trying to say it that I pretended like I
knew a lot about myself and really it's
because I knew nothing about myself and
so I had to pretend to try and get
somewhere was also very inviting and I
find myself both really hating and
sometimes really liking the guy who
wrote it
oh also aa new president yeah if you're
wondering if there's anything out there
that's by far more interesting than me
reading my old journals and talking
about my old self I suggest you watch
Barack Obama's inauguration speech
because it was pretty amazing